Heart is resting and it's waking me up at 1 to 2 a.m. Thank you. Also you got to
consider the thing that spikes at 1 or 2 o'clock in the morning is your
cortisol. So your cortisol daily rhythm cortisol is a horrible that's
produced by your adrenal glands and it spikes about 1 or 2 a.m. in the
morning for the purpose of breaking down glycogen stores in your liver into
glucose to keep your brain aligned. So if you're under a lot of stress you're
going to have issues with that and you will be waking up at 1 or 2 in the
morning because you have a deficiency of cortisol production in your
adrenals because you're under a lot of stress. So do examine that and get on an
adaptogen for the soul. If this was me I would start taking an adaptogen. So one
of this if I you know did have cancer you said well would be the one
supplement if you were stranded on a desert aisle that you would take with you it
would be adaptogens and because adaptogens help balance your hormones I'm
talking about your pituitary your thyroid your adrenals which really give you
all your energy during the day help balance glucose levels. Now there's
several good adaptogens probably one of my favorites is the adaption R3 by
by a research lab that has just been a wonderful proven standby that's this
product right there that's what I would get on if I were you look at your stress
levels try to diminish that as best you can to.